like like you think about fishing as an
activity right and on paper right it's
awful it's awesome everything that goes
wrong could go wrong you know your hands
are getting slimy when you get the fish
maybe you'll get a fish worst case
scenario you sit there for eight hours
and nothing happens you spend you spent
like an hour setting up the rod because
your [ __ ] you don't know how to fish
maybe you're with the expert he can
teach you but you tangle the the line oh
it's a [ __ ] nightmare everything goes
wrong what bait do i bring i don't know
what what what kind of hook do i bring i
don't know i hate it tying the knot on
the hook is such a pain in the ass yeah
god you've got to get the net out when
you get a fish but then [ __ ] when the
glorious big hand comes out
that's that's when it gets gooey that's
what it is that's what you buy you have
to buy the chair that has the beer
holder yeah yeah yeah yeah see i did
that for the camping trip because i know
eventually one of these days we're going
to go fishing
i'm already prepared
don't pretend that don't pretend like
you planned this i know like okay so for
the camping trip joey brought this
[ __ ] like massive
fold-out chair like not normally like a
hundred dollars yeah yeah jesus christ
joe you don't need that you're not
sunbathing yeah i am now
it wasn't one of those ones where you
could like easily fold up and like pack
into a small pack yeah like it was like
[ __ ] rectangular yeah right
like i thought because i thought most of
the the chairs that i've bought that are
like that i thought it was the ones
where you could fold like four ways into
a tube but then when it appeared i was
like why is it only folded in half
and i realized oh it's because there's
two giant metal rods
that are like keeping the entire thing
together that just won't bend yeah and i
lifted it up and i'm like why does this
thing weigh 20 kilograms
it was like it was something i was like
the greek god of this capture bring me
another grape honestly honestly honestly
the chair itself was like king [ __ ] it
was it was like it was like a [ __ ] it
wasn't every time i got up to like go
get wood or go to the toilet someone was
always like
i'm sitting in the king's chair honestly
it wasn't a camping chair it was a
[ __ ] throne
right well like don't pretend like you
did that you did that by complete
accident because i did it you know what
it was it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] to get in
the car because we were going camping
and the car was like the car
it barely fit in the boot yeah it was
barely fitting it was it was heavier
than my bag full of all of my clothes
and [ __ ] it's a seven seater and the
chair took like two seats
exactly
you took one seat and took away two yeah
fantastic i mean joe had a great time
sitting down at the end of us driving
there and having like less space oh yeah
to like sit but worth it
what the [ __ ] is that it has like a
foldable like uh table on the side and
it's like a [ __ ] like a colonial
imperialist mess oh yeah yeah going to
your new land i was like some game of
thrones [ __ ] dude like god i thought i
felt so powerful
oh man but yeah like like for like
fishing i don't know how you can enjoy
without alcohol because most of it is
just
nothing you're just sitting there yeah
you're just waiting
what you're doing
you bring the nintendo ds or you just
get drunk and talk there's only two
options
yeah that's the switch now i guess yeah
the nintendo ds just play some smash
bros while you're waiting for the field
trip i mean that's what you can do man
you dig that pole in the ground and just
start drinking exactly until you think
you've caught a fish and you're too
drunk to realize
uh we still need to go fishing yeah well
yeah i'd like to go camping and do it
properly but it seems like in japan
there's not many good camping site they
all seem very
they're very controlled very close
together yeah
it just seems like a
shitty nightmare would you rather go
fishing like off the bank or would you
rather be in a boat
ah probably off the bank and just
sitting in the chair off the bank yeah
in the boat you you you'd be very active
when you're doing it i don't know
i prefer the boat i don't know you're
gonna be in a row boat though not like a
big boat oh okay no no i'm not like a
yacht
okay another [ __ ]
the [ __ ] would i want to be in that bro
simulating i'm a i'm like a broke
fisherman in god's head boat equals
yacht
the guy was like yes i want to be on the
louis vuitton ss3
the louis vuitton ss3 that's the name of
the name of my book that's the name of
the bot though
yeah i don't wanna be in a robot and i
don't think connor wants to be on a
robot with me either because uh he'll
he'll [ __ ] find a way to tip it gone
will [ __ ] tip the boat i mean we've
been on a robo together i remember when
we went to kyoto and yeah
also just turns into like daddy long
legs in this [ __ ] way he can't just
stand up properly and he was like having
great difficulties he's going to hit the
boat he's going to tip the boat any
second now
i wanted to see that yeah he stood up
and he was just like whoa
oh my god please god god please please
yeah he was terrible at rowing
yeah i don't know i don't i didn't i
don't know what i was doing wrong i
don't know i think he just kept putting
it in and then just pulling it out you
didn't just like row i don't know
i'm just kind of like you know i feel i
feel like i'm like you know i quagmire
or something where where you have he has
like one one arm stronger offer he's
like
sucks though really i enjoy it
not not when the conditions that we were
doing yeah we were we were doing it in a
japanese summer oh
my time i left my back was like that my
shirt was a different color yeah that's
not cool the fall is really really nice
i was doing manual labor in the summer
i don't even do manual labor normally
let alone in the summer and we were
hungover as well
i probably hate it too
honestly doing anything outside in
japanese summers is just like nope nope
let's let's just let's just do an indoor
activity the the weekly reminder the
japanese summer sucks we're gonna keep
complaining about it until it's over
yeah right yeah i love winter winter's
the beast yeah i don't know man i just i
just don't understand people who who
just like this heat and this humidity
psychopaths man talk about this i get it
man
i mean god i felt so bad for the [ __ ]
olympians right like we talked about
this but jesus christ